un sujet un seul sujet avec luc godbout
la prestation fédérale d'urgence pour
soir luc godbout
bonsoir si je vous disais ai demandé de
résumer en quelques mots tout ce qu'on
doit savoir de cette nouvelle prestation
alors tout ce qu'on doit savoir c'est la
prestation canadienne d'urgence est
annoncée hier a été votée il remplace
les locations de soins d'urgence et
l'allocation de soutien d'urgence qui
avait été annoncé la semaine précédent
donc on oublie ça une seule prestation
500 $ par semaine d'où le 2000 par mois
et il est applicable pour 16 semaines
qui a droit
quiconque a cessé son emploi à cause de
lakovic 19 ça comprend les travailleurs
autonomes
ça comprend les gens qu'ils doivent
rester chez eux les malades en
quarantaine ceux qui prennent soin d'un
proche également alors conditions
d'admissibilité de base avoir gagné 5000
dollars en 2019 ou dans les 12 derniers
mois et cesser de d'avoir un revenu de
travail pour au moins 14 jours
consécutifs donc c'est ça la barre vient
pour se qualifier à ce nouveau programme
prestation canadienne daujan on reçoit
des tonnes de questions nous en avons
sélectionné quelques-unes qui permettra
de préciser davantage encore tout ce que
vous dites si le gouvernement me donne
l'aide d'urgence de 2000 $ par mois mais
que mon assurance emploi me donnait
droit à 1500 par mois vais-je devoir
rembourser le 500 dollars par mois a
reçu en trop alors lorsqu'il pour
préciser d'avec cette question là si la
personne a des est déjà allé à
l'assurance emploi
si elle reçoit déjà de
l'assurance-emploi 1500 $ elle dresse à
l'assurance emploi
elle peut pas migrer vers la prestation
canadienne d'urgence pour recevoir 2000
$ par mois donc ça si vous êtes déjà sur
l'assurance emploi vous rester là si
vous êtes sur l'assurance emploi mais
qu'elle doit se terminer dans les
prochains jours semaines ou avant le 3
octobre prochain
là au terme de l'assurance emploi vous
allez devenir admissible à la prestation
canadienne de
gensse si je comprends la question un
peu différemment et que l'on nous nous
trouvions dans une situation où une
personne en situation normale qui aurait
perdu son emploi qui aurait eu doit
l'assurance emploi normal et qui aurait
reçu 1500 $ par mois
là maintenant si elle perd son emploi
après le 15 mars elle va avoir droit
la prestation canadienne d'urgence de
2000 dollars par mois fait et donc elle
n'aura pas à rembourser
l'excédent de 2 500 $ ok autre question
est ce qu'un minimum de revenus gagner
annuellement pour avoir accès les
nouvelles prestations canadiennes
d'urgence c'est 5000 $ on l'a déjà dit
est ce que les dividendes reçus en 2019
compte dans le calcul des revenus par
exemple
alors il ya beaucoup de choses qui
rentrent c'est naturellement revenu
d'emploi revenus travailleurs autonomes
si vous avez l'assurance emploi des
prestations du régime québécois
d'assurance parentale tout ça va compter
mais non les dividendes ne rentre pas ça
ne fait pas partie ça alors on a souvent
déjà en pme qui sont un actionnaire
unique de leur entreprise ils peuvent se
rémunérer où se verser des salaires ou
du dividende
si l'on opté pour uniquement du
dividende ils ne seront pas admissibles
à cette prestation un étudiant qui a
perdu son emploi à temps partiel dans un
restaurant à cause de la coved 19
il gagne 150 dollars par semaine et ce
qu'il est admissible
alors cet étudiant la cie dans l'année
2019 ou dans les 12 derniers mois il a
gagné plus de 5000 $ oui ils voient est
admissible s'il perd son emploi et
qu'ils ne travaillent pas pendant 14
jours consécutifs
ils vont être admissibles les
prestations canadiennes d'urgence de 500
$ par semaine ils vont être plus riche
avec la prestation canadienne d'urgence
en ville et avec son emploi à temps
partiel
que vont-ils faire pour ceux qui sont
éligibles à l'assurance emploi et qui
devait toucher le montant maximal de 500
73 $ par semaine
est-ce qui sera converti directement aux
2000 $ par mois non quelqu'un qui perd
son emploi actuellement
aujourd'hui le keeper son d'emploi et
pis c'est parce que des bons salaires
qu'ils auraient droit au maximum donc à
la prestation de 573 aulas peut dès
maintenant faire sa demande à
l'assurance emploi va voir la semaine
de carence et il va pouvoir avoir droit
à ces prestations il peut avoir un petit
délai ou cette personne ne peut choisir
d'attendre de s'inscrire dans le nouveau
dans la nouvelle prestation est à voir
le 2000 mais elle peut opter pour
l'assurance emploi
une chose est sûre pour propos que les
gens parce qu'il pouvait y avoir de
confusion on peut pas demander les deux
prestations en simultané nom de ça c'est
limpide limpide limpide leur a fait
autre question je reçois des prestations
de vieillesse mais je dois continuer à
travailler à temps partiel
maintenant j'ai perdu cet emploi est ce
que je peux recevoir l'aide d'urgence de
2000 $ par mois alors aux deux bouts du
spectre
un peu comme l'étudiant qui
travaillaient à temps partiel notre
ennemi qui travaillent à temps partiel
s'il a gagné 5000 dollars en 2019 ou
dans les 12 derniers mois
s'il travaillait présentement même à
temps partiel etc sont d'emploi doit
cesser à cause de lakovic 19 ils vont
être admissible oui à la prestation
canadienne au genre et contrairement à
l'assurance emploi de normal s'il reçoit
des prestations du régime des rentes du
québec ne viendra pas affecté à la
baisse cette prestation canadienne
d'urgence donc il a droit à 500 $ par
semaine
excellence est très clair autre question
la fin de mon chômage concorde avec le
début de la crise la coved 19
suis-je tout de même éligibles à cette
allocation d'urgence alors les gens qui
étaient déjà sur l'assurance emploi et
qui doivent revoir leur prestation
arrêtés et mettront entre le 15 mars et
le 3 octobre prochain
bon me grey vont pouvoir migrer sur la
nouvelle prestation canadienne d'urgence
oui sans problème
autre question luc merci est ce que la
prestation canadienne d'urgence permet
aux travailleurs mis à pied de
travailler quelques heures par semaine
afin de se rapprocher d'un salaire dit
complet actuellement la loi est quand
même assez clair sadi a cessé ses
activités pendant 14 jours consécutifs
n'a pas pu travailler pendant 14 jours
consécutifs alors quelqu'un qui
continuerait de travailler un petit peu
ne se qualifierait pas à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence il n'y aurait pas
droit donc ils perdraient au complet la
prestation que les zones d'urgence
mais là
on a vu la loi on n'a pas vu les
règlements de cette prestation
canadienne d'urgence peut-être c'est peu
probable mais peut-être qu'il pourrait y
avoir des éléments de clarification dans
les règlements qui pourrait dire que
finalement oui mais a priori la réponse
est non ok une autre question j'ai passé
65 ans j'ai une supplément de revenu
garanti est ce que je suis obligé la
prestation canadienne d'urgence
a priori les gens qui auront qui ont 65
ans et plus qui ont du supplément de
revenu garanti n'ont pas de revenus
d'emploi la réponse serait non
si par contre c'est comme l'aîné
précédent qui maintenaient une activité
d'emploi qui a fait plus de 5000 $ dans
la dernière année et qui perd son emploi
dans le cadre de lakovic 19 la réponse
deviendrai oui donc on peut avoir et le
supplément de revenu garanti et la
prestation canadienne d'urgence mais
fallait avoir un emploi il faut le
perdre dans le contexte de lakovic 19
voilà le godbout vous étiez limpide
merci beaucoup
y'a pas de quoi